هذه نقطه كانت قد برزت منذ بدايه الهجوم
الروسي على اوكرانيا وهي تتطال الامراض
ايضا البحر اسافه والبحر الاسود الاكيد
انه خلال تنقلنا هنا في اوكرانيا الكثير
من الحقول الاوكرانيه زرعت
بالغامه وسط رفض الجانب الروسي اعطاء
الجانب الاوكراني خريطه لها خصوصا بعد
انسحابه
الاخيره من مناطق جنوب اوكرانيا هذا ما
جعل مثلا السكان يحكمون بتحديده
والاختصاصيين طبعا بمساعده الاقتصاد
طرقات محدده تحديدا داخل الحقول الموحله
للغايه في هذه الفتره من السنه هذه نقطه
نقطه ثانيه لها علاقه بالخطر المقبل مع
امكانيه تشكل طبقات الثلج والجليد خلال
الفتره المقبله ذلك سيزيد ومن الممكن ان
يزيد عدد اه الضحيه خصوصا مع غياب
الكهرباء لجوء الكثير من الاوكرانيين الى
توجه الى الغابات لقطع ال- اا حطب من اجل
التدفئه وهذا ما يشكل خطرا اا كبيرا نعلم
ان هناك العديد من انواع
الالغام التي زرعت بعضها مضاد للالياف لكن
الجانب الاوكراني يتحدث ايضا عن انغام
مضاده للاشخاص ثم ان هناك همم خطرا اخر
يتم التحديث منه ايه اذا انه عند قصف
الابنيه او المراكز العسكريه هناك الكثير
من الذخيره التي لا تنفجر لكنها تبقى هشه
وغير مستقره وبالتالي احيانا تتحدث
المراكز الطبيه عن اصابات بعد الدوس عليها
اما عن طريق الخطا او محاوله
لمسها همم او نقلها
مخاطر ومن اجل العمليه القيام بعمليه
تنظيف الحقول تحديدا استعدادا لاعاده
زرعها في الموسم المقبل هذا الامر يكلف
الملايين وفي حاجه الى اختصاصيين كنا قد
شاهدنا على وصول متطوعين من مناطق متعدده
من العالم لكن هذا يبقى غير كافن ذلك انه
هناك حاجه الى ميزانيه كبيره والقيام
بخطوات مدروسه من اجل على الاقل تامين
المناطق
القريبه من السكان والحقول التي يحتاجها
الاوكرانيون تحديدا حقول القمح الشافعه
هنا في اوكرانيا
الخاصه شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من الدروش
كيف شكرا ميساء